this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
today's episode jonathan is taking
another look at the guns of valorant
we've got this
opening holographic site but when we go
into aiming down the sight as it were we
get a what i think is an artificial zoom
that it's moving the player's point of
view forward rather than the sight
acting as a telescopic magnified optic
make sure to check out the previous
episode we did of the weapons of
valorent there's a link to it in the
description below and while you're there
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out future episodes with jonathan and if
there are any other games guns mechanics
that you guys want to see jordan break
down let us know in the comment section
below right let's take a look at more of
the guns of valerian
curse you dave for your charms
we've got a little golden coffee pot i
think probably because he couldn't find
the teapot we are british after all and
this thing looks a heck of a lot like
the beretta px4 storm polymer framed
nine millimeter pistol it's not it's
different in uh i haven't got one to
compare annoyingly but it's different in
most details that i can recall but it
has to be inspired by that for example
the
disassembly levers are very glock the
ones on the px4 are different to that
the serrations are different but there's
definitely some reference there and we
have this consistent aesthetic of orange
night sights well however they're
supposed to work i don't know i suppose
it's a little interesting that we still
have well actually i don't know i
haven't read up on um on this universe
which i should have done really
it's a reaction video i'm entitled in
terms of uh
what level of technology we're operating
at because hammerfire pistols are still
around but the strong trend is away from
those and i can't help thinking that we
will eventually lose the hammers because
they are well the kind the kind of the
very least they're just as good and i
think many would argue striker 5 is
better for various reasons i won't get
into that argument just something that i
noticed i'm imagining this is gonna work
much like every other basic pistol in a
video game let's have a look
on the money
right first thing i noticed is video
game recoil quite old school actually in
a way in that it's coming straight back
toward me and not there's no muzzle rise
and thinking about it probably all the
guns in the game
operate that way if we were going for
realism then yeah muzzle rise probably
ought to be in there we've also got an
alternate fire mode so
this is not just your bog standard
starting pistol from a video game this
does have another another feature and it
i don't really know how it's supposed to
work but it's a sort of
slow three-round burst real burst fire
on pistols is inevitably extremely high
because of the way they operate and it's
sort of is creating a sort of shotgun
pattern on the target so again i'm not
really sure how that would work these
are very small rounds how do you contain
that many pieces of shot in a tiny
little pistol round answer is you don't
but the real answer is it's a game
uh a sub machine gun of course we've got
to have a submachine gun in the game
more than one i think bitter bit of a
ump vibe from this but not not massively
maybe the being the modern bmt
submachine guns as well we have one of
those but honestly it's not close enough
to
to make the comparison with it's it's
pretty generic it's a cool design but um
nothing directly based on anything i
wouldn't have said probably the ump is
the closest and nothing too exciting on
the sci-fi front i will say the recessed
sight rail is quite a nice touch that
might actually impede how the thing
would work but we won't go there i'll be
won't go any further into that but what
it does mean is you end up with sights
that coincide quite
they're a good height for where your
face is on the stock
and they line up with your iron sights
or potentially even co-witness with them
so that the point of view of the front
sight is the same as the dot of the
holographic side would be the reason for
doing this and of course what we see
nowadays is the whole top of the gun is
a rail this has gone back in time and i
think that's probably ump inspired
because if you look at the ump you'll
see two mounting holes in the top of the
receiver
for an optic rail the ump came out with
an optical sight optical rails with full
length rails anyway were not quite the
thing yet but it was more advanced than
an mp5 where you have to clamp on a claw
mount for your side so you mount a piece
of rail or not
somewhat predictably although that's not
really a criticism we have a massive
anti-materiel rifle i'm only seeing the
left side at the moment looks
bolt-action it looks like various big
amrs like the black arrow
say and to be fair i don't have a scale
yet so i'm not sure if this is meant to
be a true anti-materiel rifle or a large
caliber sniper rifle it has got a break
big heavy fluted barrel and it looks
like it's massive oh and the magazine is
quite huge too quite a conventional
looking scope again with turrets and
rings surprisingly conventional for a
science fiction setting because they've
gone for a sort of integrated receiver
look similar to the original m98
at b barrett where the stock is kind of
not adjustable it's right now i'm
driving at it's kind of stuck where it
is and that is i think unlikely some
sort of adjustable stock i would imagine
is going to become standard on
absolutely everything it's already
standard on infantry rifles and we don't
seem to have that now we do have a big
what looks like a big rubber butt pad as
well
suggests that this thing is super
powerful let's see
[Applause]
now that i have a scale for this it's
more of a i guess a magnum caliber
sniper rifle 338 something like that i
don't think it's meant to be 50 bmg or
or an anti-material that said it looks
like it's on the edge because of that
break this is the implied sort of sense
of power yeah this this is much more
there's probably probably a line back
from this to counter strike as the whole
get more watch of the gameplay the more
i see this is a more sci-fi successor to
the counter-strike series i do feel
duty-bound to say once again that i just
don't think we'll have bolt-action
sniper rifles and material rifles bolt
action anything in the future not for
not for military paramilitary type use
i'm sure i'm sure there will be
situations in 50 000 years where we're
still using them but for frontline
service i just don't see that there'll
be an advantage modern machining and
engineering is sophisticated enough that
sniper rifles can be semi-automatic and
are temporary automatic there may be a
sense of tradition there that keeps
things going clearly at the moment there
are still a lot of voltage sniper rifles
don't get me wrong but yeah i can't see
that lasting forever
all right i've got the i've not been
paying attention to names thus far but
um this is the guardian and real
m14 vibes from this thing
i mean even the flash hider is somewhat
reminiscent but the fact he's got a gas
tube under the barrel with that vertical
gas block the even the stock is a little
reminiscent of modernized m14 ebr type
chassis stocks the the action is kind of
if you really squint
feels a little bit m14 as well but then
it sort of incorporated some
more modern ergonomics but then so do
the modern m14 chassis and stocks we've
got it still got a paddle magazine
release like an m14 let's see if my m14
impressions are borne out by the
gameplay
yep so we have a
sort of operating rod fixed cocking
handle bolts arrangements and the the
size the scale the theft of this thing
definitely is in line with it being a an
m14 in space i've said that before i
can't remember what about the m14 really
is i think it's fair to say more iconic
in popular culture now than it ever was
in military history i know some some
some emergency
people are going to start shouting at me
for saying that but in terms of its
success as a standard issue frontline
infantry rifle it didn't quite get where
it needed to get but you know all of all
gamers know what no1 m14 is and so we
keep getting these echoes of it as the
sort of big hefty brother to something
like an ar or an ak and here it is again
i noticed when the guns counted over to
the left you can actually see the brass
of the rounds underneath i won't go off
again on my halo rant about why we're
using brass case cartridges in the
future this this more made me think
about sealing mechanisms against dirt
that kind of thing there are firearms
where you can see bits of
cartridge case through the through the
action it's quite rare because generally
if you can see it dirt can get in and
cause some sort of an issue i like
visually i like the fact that you can
see the rounds in the magazine sitting
below the bolt if this were a practical
modern rifle i don't think we would have
this fully sealed when the bolts shut
against whatever it may be sand dirt
snow
healer's down
now something you see with this is we've
got we've got this uh opening
holographic side but it's quite far down
the barrel because it can't be where the
bolt is admittedly it could be further
back than it is but when we go into
aiming down the sight as it were we get
a what i think is an artificial zoom um
it's moving the player's point of view
forward rather than the sight acting as
a telescopic magnified optic it isn't
it's a standard for the game holographic
sight i think that's that's sort of an
artificial effect just for the sort of a
comfortable view for the player
odin seems like quite an appropriate
name for this beast okay what am i
seeing here well massive 4 chamber no
2 chamber
either way massive muzzle break which
gives me a sense of scale i think and
that these are 50
vmg or equivalent very conventional
looking rounds quite conventional
looking links as well while we're at it
but it's got a sort of saw grip at the
back it doesn't look very ergonomically
comfortable a massive great belt box
underneath a side grip as well yeah this
is probably the most sci-fi looking gun
we've seen so far but it does
purport i think to operate on modern
principles i.e gas operation
conventional ammunition
let's check it out
all right so we've got one feature of
modern like contempt very contemporary
machine belt fed machine guns which is a
short top cover older belt fed guns
tended to have a very long unwieldy top
cover it gave you very little option for
very secure mounting of optics although
in this case the optic rail is still on
top of the top cover but hey it is on
some modern machine guns as well anyway
a shorter top cover makes is easier to
lock solidly into place it's the current
trend i think in belt fed machine gun
architecture and we see it here albeit
released by a somewhat remote feeling
button so you press the button and it
pops open it doesn't quite seem to have
that mechanical connection that i would
expect on a conventional
gun that the ergonomics of these of this
side grip and that rear grip are not
good this very very heavy bulky gun is
going to is going to twist in your hands
big time if you're going to fire
something like this unsupported which of
course we are it's a non-realistic
shooter then a sore trunk
or a um sorry chainsaw type grip over
the top of the gun would make a bit more
sense off to one side i'm not really a
fan of that
wow that's quite the rate of fire for
something that appears to be on the
order of a 50 caliber so fast that the
rounds just seem to judder in place they
don't seem to actually move through the
gun and it seems like the rate of fire
in common with some other big old
machine guns in games goes up the longer
you hold down the button which i presume
makes it harder to control but i'm not
really seeing any vertical spread
that would go along with that i've got a
big tubular cocking handle on the right
hand side reminiscent of the mg42 but
also the smart gun which the mg42 is
built into from aliens of course yeah so
that that's increased rate of fire from
holding down your firing button or
trigger is represented by the barrel and
the muzzle device interestingly heating
up to a glowing orange
just as a i guess a visual indicator so
you maybe just for fun
probably needless to say gun barrels can
get glowing orange or red or even white
hot but it requires a lot of firing a
lot of firing more than a burst even at
this very high rate even with this very
high pressure round you're not going to
get visibly glowing
and if you did it wouldn't well yeah
it's a visual conceit detail there on
the cocking so we've got we've got
correctly for a belt fed gun pull the
cocking handle back return it forward
but in this case you get a cocking sound
both in both directions implying that
this thing is closed bolt and you're
riding the cocking handle forward that's
not why you do that on a belt fed gun
you do that to [ __ ] it into the open
position and then you return the cocking
handle forward so that it's not then
flapping around under recoil it then it
latches forward and it's there ready to
collect the bolt in the closed position
when the gun is empty that's why you do
that so this is um aping what has been
seen in either videos or range actual
range shooting i don't know of a real
belt fed gun but it's gone in a sort of
fantasy direction that's not a criticism
i'm fascinated by details like that and
second guessing where things come from
okay it is classic video game magnum
revolver time we have a cylinder that's
a little bit reminiscent of the kiapa
with it's the rhino that is with its
flat faceted design but it also has a
futuristic take on fluting the grooves
in the side in well on each chamber
essentially or possibly adjacent to
can't quite see yeah between the between
the rounds effectively now that it would
be there on a real gun to lighten the
gun
that's really all it's there for
although it does have an aesthetic
definitely has an aesthetic aspect too
because you will find completely smooth
modern revolvers with complete smooth
cylinders all with flutes and
yes if you go for the smooth look you
are adding a little bit of weight but
it's not hugely significant we've got a
quite a science fiction look to this but
it's still grounded enough that it
doesn't look like a nerf maverick or
something it looks like a swing out
cylinder with a push button latch it has
a hammer all pretty conventional
let's have a look
oh all right this appears to be what's
often called an auto revolver like the
table players having to [ __ ] it before
use pressing the trigger is just
dropping the hammer it's not revolving
the cylinder and then on firing the
hammer is being blown back or returned
to the to the rearward position somehow
and the cylinder is then being rotated
implying some kind of a gas system or a
mechanical recoil operated system to do
those two things to advance the
cylinders to the next round and to
re-cock the hammer the the original auto
revolver would be the webby fosbury
which actually had a reciprocating upper
frame
in order to do those two jobs how this
one works i don't know but what would
appear to be a conventional swing out
cylinder magnum revolver
is de facto some sort of automatic
revolver advantage of that in theory
would be a very light accurate trigger
pull the disadvantage would be
complexity weight
cost none of which you have to worry
about in this game
it does look like we have fudged the
reload here when the empties are kicked
out the cylinder they still have bullets
on them they're not empty cases i think
i'm right in saying that uh also the
ejector rod is literally an
old-fashioned ejector rod by the look of
it that you would have to slap for the
ejector star to kick out the empty cases
but this somehow does it itself just
with a flick of the wrist the rod goes
flying back and and kicks out the
empties doesn't it wouldn't shouldn't
work like that unless it's somehow
rigged to do that and i don't know how
it would be but i also don't know how it
operates
uh if you'd like to support the work
that we do at the armories we'd love you
to come and visit one of our three sites
if you can you we're in the uk so that's
a problem for some of you otherwise
check out our website our various social
media outlets and of course i will see
you again next time
[Music]
[Music]
you